hi in this video we are going to talk
about
two subclass of t cells one is alpha
beta t
cell and second is the gamma delta t
cell and this classification
is based on the difference in their t
cell receptor
also the abundance of these two subtypes
of t cells are different
we're going to talk about all of that so
today's focus is
gamma delta t cell and how gamma delta t
cell is different
from alpha beta tcr containing t cells
generally the t cells that we talk about
the cd4 positive or cd8 positive t cells
they are generally
alpha beta tcr containing t cells and
their classification is based on whether
they have a cd4
receptor or a cd8 receptor but in this
case we are going to talk about
the classification based on the t cell
receptor itself not the co receptor
now we all know that the t cell
development takes place
in thymus and it takes
several weeks for this development and
there are several stages of the
development process right and
development takes place at different
strata inside the thymus
so the first stage is called double
negative stage
when the commitment towards t cell
lineage
takes place and not signaling has huge
role to play in that if you don't know
how t cell lineage commitment takes
place i have a video on that
click on the link in the description now
we are going to focus on how t
cell receptor rearrangement takes place
and how alpha beta or gamma delta t
cells are produced
so t cell even there in the dominant
negative
the double negative stage they can be
divided into four sub stages
dn 1 2 three and four and they are
identified
based on different type of surface
expression of receptors
a combinatorial expression but what is
important
is between the stage of dominant
negative one
between the stages of double negative
one and double negative two
beta chain rearrangement takes place
so beta chain means that beta chain of
the t cell receptor
rearrangement takes place at this
particular time frame
after that after the dn4 stage
the alpha chain rearrangement takes
place so now we can see at the end of
dn4 stage alpha beta rearrangement is
complete
and this might give rise to a tcr
containing alpha and beta
receptor right later on these receptors
would be tested for their affinity
towards
antigen what type of antigens they are
recognizing and from where but this is
the basic rearrangement process
now what i wanted to tell you that vdj
recombination is not
only applicable for b cell receptors it
is also applicable for t cell receptor
so t cell receptor genes are also having
vdj segments for example the beta gene
segments have
vdj segments right and they rearrange
and first beta chain rearrangement takes
place followed by
the alpha chain rearrangement as we have
already seen
now if you look at the gene segments
then we would see there are beta
alpha chain gene segments beta change in
segments
are very similar to the delta chain gene
segments because
both beta and delta chain gene segments
have v d
j segments whereas alpha and gamma chain
gene segments are pretty similar both
have v
and j segments so these segments can
undergo recombination right v dj
recombination or vj recombination
and there is a probability of this
recombination event
so let us talk about that now the alpha
beta or the gamma delta tcr
rearrangement
have different probabilities how because
first of all
at dn1 to dn2 transition already the
beta chain rearrangement is done
now in order to become a alpha beta t
cell it only need to rearrange one chain
that means the alpha chain only
but in order to become a gamma delta t
cell
or gamma delta tcr containing t cell it
has to rearrange
two chains now rearrangement of two
chain
is less likely than rearrangement of one
chain
and as a result gamma delta t cells
comprises only 25 percent of the total t
cell population so they are very less in
number
so it is three times more likely that a
t cell would become
alpha beta tcr containing t cell than a
gamma data containing t
cells it turns out during pregnancy or
during the gestational period
the gamma delta t cell number is high
but as the development
progress and after birth the gamma delta
t cell
count decreased dramatically where alpha
beta
tcr containing t cell number is
increasing
now there are quite a lot of
there are quite quite a lot of debate
about their functions
what are the functions of gamma delta t
cell or alpha beta t cells
but what it talk what is
known that alpha beta t cells are
important for combating pathogens or all
of these things whereas gamma delta t
cell
give immunity against protozoal
infection
at least it is known in case of mice so
let us try to
summarize the point between alpha beta t
c rs and gamma delta tcr so alpha beta
tcr
rearrangement is more likely to occur
whereas gamma delta
tcr rearrangement is rare and less
likely to occur
and the alpha beta tcr containing t
cells are higher in number
compared to the gamma delta tc are
containing t cells
moreover the alpha beta tcr are more
diverse
when it comes to antigen recognition
compared to the gamma delta t
cells so in this video we pretty much
looked at the
development of the gamma delta t cells
where they developed
and gamma delta gene rearrangement and
we also compared alpha beta t cell
with gamma delta t cells and appreciated
their
differences so i hope you enjoyed this
video if you like this video give it a
quick thumbs up don't forget to like
share and subscribe thank you and do let
me know in the comment how do you like
my video your comments give me so much
positive motivation such
that i can make more videos thank you
guys